si ha dicho especialmente a los países
del g7 que recordemos son las potencias
del mundo sin china y sin rusia que
deben acordarse estándares de respeto de
los derechos humanos el respeto de las
mujeres y de las niñas a seguir
educándose a no tener nexos con el
terrorismo y con el narcotráfico antes
de que algún país reconozca al talibán
como un nuevo gobierno en este debate
extraordinario que se realiza en este
momento en el parlamento británico ha
sido especialmente difícil para el
gobierno johnson porque he tenido que
enfrentar críticas por la falta de
preparación ante esta crisis humanitaria
la falta de inteligencia que no previó
que el talibán se apropiaría de
afganistán tan rápidamente johnson dijo
que juzgaremos a este régimen por las
decisiones que tome por sus acciones más
que por sus palabras y reitero que las
tropas británicas no volverán a
afganistán y tampoco a través de la otan
luisa y también reinó unido- acoger a
los refugiados de afganistán pero desde
ya se critica que eso no es suficiente
quienes están detrás de estas críticas
las críticas vienen de distintos
sectores desde el parlamento de
organizaciones de derechos humanos que
velan por los refugiados del mundo y han
dicho que cinco mil personas este año no
son suficientes dado que se está en el
pico de la crisis que es necesario
acoger más el gobierno ha explicado que
los próximos años acoger a 20.000
personas más de afganistán pero se
critica especialmente la tardanza en
recibirlas y básicamente ha explicado el
gobierno en que es muy complejo recoger
a personas de afganistán porque hay que
organizar les una vida nueva aquí
entretanto siguen las críticas por la
tardanza del gobierno para evacuar a sus
nacionales y a los afganos que han
trabajado por tantos años en servicio de
las tropas británicas como intérpretes y
sus familias de hecho se ha dicho
incluso que no será posible evacuar los
a todos a tiempo